voilà dans quelques secondes
quelques dizaines de secondes à 5,20
mourir je vous rappelle que le combat ne
fait que recommencer et que dans les
kiosques dès la semaine prochaine vous
trouverez 5 plus qui sera l'organe de
liaison avec vous les téléspectateurs
patrice oui au début de cette émission
début de cette veillée qui nous a
rassemblé qui vous a rassemblé j'ai
parlé de tristesse et de fierté à propos
de fierté je voudrais simplement avant
que cette chaîne ne meure rendre un
hommage particulier au sang froid à la
dignité au sens des responsabilités et
au panache on l'a vu ce soir avec
lesquels l'ensemble du personnel et la
rédaction bien sûr on travaillait depuis
la mi-décembre depuis que les
difficultés que vous connaissez ont
commencé je voulais rendre cet hommage
je crois que c'était utile à l'ensemble
du personnel
merci bonsoir